I had a dream last night that it was the best episode we've ever done.
So I couldn't sleep the rest of the night, got in here, fired up the old machine,
and I'm now waiting on these guys, and I am loose.
I got a little bit of a sweat going.
The hammies are pliable, flexible, and the jaw muscles are ready to really ask some tough questions
and giggle at my funny little friend, Sean and Will.
guys welcome to smartless
smart
昨晚我做了一个梦，梦见这是我们做过最棒的一期节目。所以我整晚都没睡着，来到这儿，启动了这台老机器，现在正等着这几位，我整个人很放松。我出了一点汗。腿筋很柔软、灵活，下巴肌肉也准备好问些尖锐的问题，并嘲笑我那两个有趣的小伙伴，肖恩和威尔。伙计们，欢迎来到SmartLess。
hi guys
shut up Sean
I've never I haven't laughed
laughed so hard as I did
today when we were standing on the street
we just come out of a
meeting the three of us
like adults
嘿，伙计们，闭嘴，肖恩。我从来没像今天这样笑得这么厉害，当时我们站在街上，刚从一个会议出来，我们三个就像成年人一样。
like adults and Sean
starts to say something
and he like he's doing right now
he he undoes a
top of a bottle of water and he's about to take his hip
or he's going to do it
and Jason slaps it out of his hand.
And lands on the ground.
就像成年人一样，肖恩开始说些什么，就像他现在做的那样，他打开一瓶水，正要喝，或者正要干点什么，杰森一把把它从他手里拍掉了。掉在了地上。
And it lands on the ground.
Just a fun, a fun little hair pole.
Yeah, just a little fun, fun, fun.
Yeah, just a plastic bottle, nothing broke.
So I reached down to grab it
because it falls at my feet,
and I hand it to Sean, and as he reaches for it,
I just drop it right before he can grab it.
它掉在了地上。只是一个有趣的小插曲。是的，只是一个小小的乐趣。是的，只是一个塑料瓶，什么也没坏。所以我弯腰去捡，因为它掉在我的脚边，我把它递给肖恩，就在他伸手去拿的时候，我赶在他拿到之前又把它扔了。
So now that's twice.
That's twice.
It's denied water.
And as it lands on the ground,
Sean reaches down together,
and Jason kicks it.
所以这是第二次了。这是第二次。这是第二次。这是第二次。水被拒绝了。当它掉在地上时，肖恩伸手去拿，杰森又踢了它一脚。
And it goes flying, hits a curb,
and goes under a parked like construction truck it explodes the top comes flying off the water's everywhere
fucking funny and i haven't laughed that hard i fell to my knees because it was show it was high school all over
again it was like uh it was a little bullying you know it made me laugh and stupid god i love
um jay did you like my cheesecake last night yeah cheese now i i would have i would have liked it a little
firmer, Sean.
Yeah, it was a little too fluff.
You know, it wasn't as gooey
它飞了出去，撞到路缘石，钻到一辆停着的工程车底下，它炸开了，盖子飞了出去，到处都是水，太他妈搞笑了，我笑得太厉害，跪在了地上，因为这就像回到了高中，就像一点点霸凌，你知道，这让我笑了，该死，我真爱他们。杰伊，你喜欢我昨晚做的芝士蛋糕吗？是的，芝士，现在我……我希望它能再硬一点，肖恩。是的，它有点太蓬松了。你知道，它不像上一个那么黏糊。
as the last one, so I feel like we're making
progress. I like that. The last one, no, I say this
as a person who I can't even boil water. So
the fact you cook anything is incredible.
It's very impressive. But also,
I didn't know, well, either
that I didn't, I've never made whipped cream
in my life. I didn't know that you just
像上一个那样，所以我感觉我们正在进步。我喜欢这样。上一个，不，我作为一个连水都烧不开的人这么说。所以你能做出任何东西都是不可思议的。这非常令人印象深刻。但还有，我不知道，或者说我从来没做过生奶油。我不知道你只需要……
pour half and half or whatever
in a bowl. And whip it. And you just start
the special whipped cream. You just start whipping it.
I was, my mind was there.
the title.
I was like, oh, you just...
Do you think it's a good idea that you've now learned how easy it is to make whipped cream?
I think so.
在碗里倒点半对半奶油之类的东西。然后搅打它。你就开始做特制生奶油了。你就开始搅打它。我当时……我的心思在那儿。标题。我当时想，哦，你只需要……你觉得你现在学会了做生奶油有多容易，这是个好主意吗？我想是的。
I think you know I'm doing it night.
Yeah, you missed out on a good cheesecake last night.
I know.
But then I found out, then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour
and a half for was a British chocolate, uh, Cadbury white chocolate bar.
No, not Cadbury.
It was another brand, but yeah.
我想是的。我想你知道我今晚就要做。是的，你昨晚错过了一个好吃的芝士蛋糕。我知道。但后来我发现，肖恩告诉我，他开车一个半小时去买的秘方是英国巧克力，呃，吉百利白巧克力棒。不，不是吉百利。是另一个牌子，但确实是。
Another brand that we're not going to mention, I guess.
We can't if you want.
It's called Milky Bar.
Well, we already mentioned Cadbury.
so I mean we're kind of committed.
But there's a, is that a thing?
Is that normal that there's a white chocolate candy bar
in most cheesecakes?
另一个我们不打算提的牌子，我想。如果你想的话，我们可以提。它叫Milky Bar。好吧，我们已经提到了吉百利。所以我的意思是，我们已经算是说出来了。但有个问题，那是真的吗？大多数芝士蛋糕里有白巧克力棒是正常的吗？
Well, no, no.
I just melted it to make kind of like the creamy part.
It was one of many ingredients.
Sorry, listening.
If you thought you tuned into SmartList, it's cookless this week.
Bakeless.
Yeah.
嗯，不，不。我只是把它融化了，做成奶油部分。它是众多配料中的一种。抱歉，听众们。如果你以为你收听的是SmartLess，这周是CookLess（不烹饪）。Bakeless（不烘焙）。Bakeless。是的。
And I was so obsessed with getting any ingredients right.
I drove an hour and a half to get it
because they don't sell them in the United States.
And what did he do, Will, when he got there?
So you drove to another country?
When he drove an hour and a half away to get this to...
What did he do while he was there?
He's like, huh, well, look, here's a rare hamburger joint
我太执着于把配料弄对了。我开车一个半小时去买它，因为美国不卖。威尔，当他到那儿时，他做了什么？所以你开车去了另一个国家？当他开车一个半小时去买这个来……他在那儿的时候做了什么？他就像，嗯，看，这儿有个罕见的汉堡店。
that we don't have near us.
Portillo.
Oh, that's why he went to Portillo's.
Yeah, and he put a big burger in his face and a shake, too, I'll bet.
Yeah, I got a shake, a piece of cake, and I got fries and a hot dog.
Wait, you got a shake?
For lunch?
Piece of cake, fries, and a hot dog.
我们附近没有的。Portillo's。哦，这就是他去Portillo's的原因。是的，我敢打赌他往嘴里塞了个大汉堡，还喝了奶昔。是的，我喝了奶昔，吃了块蛋糕，还买了薯条和热狗。等等，你喝了奶昔？当午餐？一块蛋糕，薯条和热狗。
and then two beef sandwiches.
And what's that?
Two beef sandwiches, one for Scotty.
And this is when you were on the mission
to pick up up a school bus?
White chocolate.
Yeah, well, I had, I picked up the white chocolate.
Were you buying for all the kids in the school bus?
还有两个牛肉三明治。那是什么？两个牛肉三明治，一个给斯科蒂。这就是你执行任务去接校车的时候？白巧克力。是的，好吧，我买了白巧克力。你是给校车上的所有孩子买的吗？
No.
I never get it.
So I bought like a little extra stuff
and I put it on the fridge and I'll heat it up later.
Good for you.
Thank you.
Guys, let's get started.
Oh, wow, I thought we had.
不。我从来不买。所以我买了一些额外的东西，我把它放在冰箱里，以后再加热。为你高兴。谢谢。伙计们，我们开始吧。哦，哇，我以为我们已经开始了。
This is really exciting, guys, today.
You're going to freak out.
out. Oh, it's your guest. It's my guest
today. I'm so excited, we got my favorite
red-headed firecracker
here today. She's a self-proclaimed
computer nerd, and before becoming one of
my all-time favorite full-fledged movie stars,
伙计们，今天真的很令人兴奋。你们会大吃一惊的。哦，是你的嘉宾。今天是我带来的嘉宾。我太兴奋了，我们今天请到了我最喜欢的红发小辣椒。她自称是电脑极客，在成为我一直以来最喜欢的成熟电影明星之前，
she made people websites
for free. In fact, at 14 years old,
she performed a PowerPoint presentation titled Project Hollywood
in order to convince her parents to let her drop out of high school
and move to L.A. from Arizona to pursue
her dreams of becoming an actress. Thankfully, that dream
came true so we could talk to her today.
Her name is Emma Stone.
她免费帮人做网站。事实上，14岁时，她做了一个名为“好莱坞计划”的PPT演示，为了说服父母让她从高中辍学，从亚利桑那州搬到洛杉矶去追求她成为演员的梦想。谢天谢地，那个梦想成真了，所以我们今天能和她聊天。她的名字是艾玛·斯通。
Emma Stowe.
Emma's a little under the weather.
I'm a little under the weather.
I can't believe you showed up for us.
Did you get into a big pile of bad coke last night, Emma?
Listen, you know what?
You've been there, right?
There's meetings for you.
艾玛·斯托。艾玛有点身体不适。我有点身体不适。真不敢相信你为我们露面了。艾玛，你昨晚是不是吸了一大堆劣质可卡因？听着，你知道吗？你也经历过，对吧？有为你准备的会议。
Yeah, listen, we're saving a seat for you.
I know, thank you.
Are you at home or in a hotel?
I'm in a hotel.
I should be live from our first ever sport.
Thanks for having me.
What an opening.
是的，听着，我们给你留了个座位。我知道，谢谢。你在家还是在酒店？我在酒店。我在酒店。我应该从我们有史以来第一次运动直播。谢谢你们邀请我。多么棒的开场。
Emma's been up for four days, listener.
Emma, I don't think of you as a ginger, I guess, per se, when I think of ginger.
But you are.
I'm blonde right now.
No, no, no, I'm not.
I'm actually, I'm blonde.
I have blonde hair right now, and I'm, and I'm, I was born blonde.
Well, I was born hairless, but then I grew blonde hair.
听众们，艾玛已经四天没睡了。艾玛，当我想到姜黄色头发时，我并不觉得你是姜黄色头发，本身。但你确实是。我现在是金发。不，不，不，我不是。我其实是，我是金发。我现在是金发，而且我，而且我，我出生时就是金发。好吧，我出生时没头发，但后来长出了金发。
Okay.
Hairless is my podcasting.
Sure.
Give us the full run.
Bravo.
The, yeah, then I died in red.
Yeah, you were.
You were read for a while there, yes?
好的。没头发是我的播客风格。当然。给我们讲讲全过程。太棒了。那个，是的，然后我染成了红色。是的，你有一段时间是红色的，对吧？
For a long time.
So much so that people thought it was that you were Natch Red Natch.
But I'm not read Natch.
But wasn't it true?
My mother's red Natch.
Yeah?
You had to be careful with that word Natch.
I have a son who's a Natch Jinge.
很长一段时间。以至于人们认为那是你天生的红色。但我不是天生红发。但这不是真的吗？我母亲是天生红发。是吗？你得小心那个词“天生红发”（Natch Jinge）。我有个儿子是天生红发。
Oh.
Yeah.
We love a Natch Jinge.
Oh, my gosh.
Do we ever love a Natch Jinge?
This has gotten so filthy from the very beginning.
I know.
It's fantastic.
哦。是的。我们喜欢天生红发。哦，天哪。我们难道不爱天生红发吗？这从一开始就变得如此下流。我知道。这太棒了。
That's fantastic.
That's nice.
That's funny.
Hey man.
Do you need a second?
Take a nap.
I've been up for days.
I'm so excited you're on the show with us, Emma.
这太棒了。那很好。那很有趣。嘿，伙计。你需要一秒钟吗？小睡一会儿。我已经好几天没睡了。艾玛，我很高兴你能和我们一起上节目。
Thanks for having.
But wait, didn't you die it originally, like when you moved here and you felt like you weren't getting parts or something?
I feel like I read something.
And then you thought maybe your talent, which you're, you know, seeping talent, that that wasn't good enough.
And that's what I was telling everyone.
Yes.
And that's what I kept saying.
Right.
谢谢你们邀请。但等等，你最初不是染了头发吗？就像当你搬到这儿，觉得接不到戏的时候？我觉得我读到过什么。然后你觉得也许你的才华，你知道，溢出的才华，那还不够好。而那是我一直在告诉大家的。是的。而那是我一直在说的。对。
And they went, no, no, no.
That hair has got to go.
But you thought you had to dye your hair?
Is that true?
Yeah, I was, because I moved to L.A. when I was 15,
and so all of the things that I was auditioning for at that time were kind of, you know,
like roles for 15-year-old girls at that time were a lot of girls that were, I guess,
what I was up for was a lot of very blonde cheerleadery kind of roles,
然后他们说，不，不，不。那头发必须得换。但你以为你必须染头发？那是真的吗？是的，我是，因为我15岁搬到洛杉矶，所以当时我试镜的所有东西都是，你知道，比如当时15岁女孩的角色，很多女孩都是，我想我争取的是很多非常金发的啦啦队长之类的角色，
and I didn't fit those very well.
And so I thought if I died my hair brown, it would really set me.
Yeah. How'd that go?
You know, it went great, Jason.
It went really great.
I didn't get any parts after that either.
But a couple of years later, I auditioned for Superbad.
And I was at the camera test for that.
而我不太适合那些。所以我以为如果我把头发染成棕色，它真的会让我……是的。结果怎么样？你知道，结果很好，杰森。结果真的很好。那之后我也没接到任何角色。但几年后，我试镜了《太坏了》。我在那部戏的摄像测试中。
And Judd Apatow said, well, maybe she could have red hair
because the other girl in the movie,
who's my best friend now, Martha McIsaac, had brown hair.
And so we dyed my hair red.
and the rest was, you know.
But is Sean's incredible research accurate?
Were you really doing websites for people?
Like, are you a computer person?
贾德·阿帕图说，嗯，也许她可以留红头发，因为电影里的另一个女孩，现在是我最好的朋友，玛莎·麦萨克，留着棕色头发。所以我们把我的头发染成了红色。剩下的就是，你知道的。但肖恩令人难以置信的研究准确吗？你真的在帮人做网站吗？就像，你是电脑达人吗？
I was in that kind of, you know, 90s computer format.
I don't know if you guys know, you know, Angel Fire, GeoCities, that kind of world where you did.
Very primitive HTML.
This is not coding by any means.
I would not, if you, in fact, I don't have a computer now.
They lent me this computer to be able to do this with you guys.
Oh, do you not do you.
I'm like a Neo-Ludite now.
我处于那种，你知道，90年代的电脑格式。我不知道你们知不知道，你知道，Angel Fire，GeoCities，那种世界，你做……非常原始的HTML。这绝不是编程。我不会，如果你，事实上，我现在没有电脑。他们借给我这台电脑，好让我能和你们一起做这个。哦，你没有吗？我现在就像个新卢德分子。
But back then, I was very into the Internet
and learning about, you know, building drop-down menus and things like that.
I mean, primitive, like, 1998.
What are you looking for?
When you're out there, you're looking,
what are you looking for in a drop-down menu?
Now, see, that's the thing.
See, that's the thing.
但那时，我非常沉迷于互联网，学习关于，你知道，建立下拉菜单之类的东西。我的意思是，原始的，就像1998年那样。你在找什么？当你在那儿的时候，你在找，你在下拉菜单里找什么？现在，看，这就是重点。看，这就是重点。
When you want somebody to step...
And this keeps me up at night.
If you want somebody, if somebody's looking to step into a really elite drop-
If you're looking for great drop-down in the market.
No, okay.
It needs to be clear, clear, fonts.
We're not using any comic sans on my drop-down items.
No, no, no, no.
当你想要某人……这让我彻夜难眠。如果你想要某人，如果有人想进入一个非常精英的下拉……如果你在市场上寻找很棒的下拉菜单。不，好吧。它需要清晰，清晰的字体。我的下拉菜单项里不会使用任何Comic Sans字体。不，不，不，不。
We're hitting Helvetica hard.
You now are completely, you don't have a computer at all?
I don't have a computer at all anymore.
Come on.
I really don't.
What about an iPhone?
I have an iPhone, but it's a very cracked.
The incredible new iPhone 15.
我们正在大力使用Helvetica。你现在完全，你根本没有电脑了？我再也没有电脑了。得了吧。我真的没有。那iPhone呢？我有iPhone，但它非常碎。令人难以置信的新iPhone 15。
I don't.
Sean?
Is this an ad for the thing?
If you want to get rid of your old one.
It is now. We're done with that. Cycles over.
Thank God.
We enjoyed our experience, but oh, mama, was there a heavy rotation?
Sorry about that, America.
我没有。肖恩？这是那个东西的广告吗？如果你想处理掉你的旧手机。现在是了。我们结束了。周期结束了。谢天谢地。我们享受了我们的体验，但哦，妈妈，那里的轮换很重吗？抱歉，美国。
Wait, so you do, but do you do email off your phone then?
I do email on my phone and I, you know, just type it with my thumbs.
So no social media, no nothing else.
No.
I love that.
Come on.
No.
That's refreshing.
等等，所以你确实，但你用手机收发邮件吗？我在手机上收发邮件，而且我，你知道，只是用大拇指打字。所以没有社交媒体，没有其他任何东西。没有。我喜欢这样。得了吧。没有。那很令人耳目一新。
Thanks so much.
You know, I was thinking yesterday, I said to a friend of ours,
I says to him, I says, friend.
I says friend, I says.
I said, we should, imagine the reset
this planet would get
if we had no social media for six months.
Globally.
太感谢了。你知道，我昨天在想，我对我们的一个朋友说，我对他说，我说，朋友。我说朋友，我说。我说，我们应该，想象一下，如果我们六个月没有社交媒体，这个星球会得到怎样的重置。全球范围内。
Yeah, it'd be pretty wild.
The fucking reset would be incredible.
What do you think would happen?
Well, people would learn how to manage boredom,
which I think is a lost talent.
I know I'd try to teach my kids like,
it's okay if you're bored.
That's actually another word for relaxation.
是的，那会很疯狂。那他妈的重置会是不可思议的。你觉得会发生什么？嗯，人们会学会如何管理无聊，我认为这是一种失传的天赋。我知道我会试着教我的孩子们，比如，如果你感到无聊也没关系。那实际上是放松的另一个词。
Like enjoy it take a breath
Being bored is okay like not having anything to do at a red light or an elevator is a good time to kind of like
Reintroduce yourself to yourself for a minute
You know? Well yeah do you ever do that thing? I mean like when you look at people
I've been doing a lot lately well I don't know where I look around and I go
Everybody's on their phone every moment if there's a if there's a down moment and sometimes it's reflexive because people are nervous or you know
It's addictive. Yeah, but when you you wake
up in the morning, you don't have like a loop
就像享受它，深呼吸。感到无聊是可以的，就像在红绿灯或电梯里没什么事可做，是一个重新认识自己的好时机，你知道吗？嗯，是的，你做过那种事吗？我的意思是，就像当你看着人们，我最近经常做，嗯，我不知道我在哪里环顾四周，我说每个人每时每刻都在看手机，如果有一个，如果有一个空闲时刻，有时这是反射性的，因为人们很紧张，或者你知道，这会上瘾。是的，但当你早上醒来时，你没有像……
that you like to do on a computer.
This is good. Hang on.
What's your computer loop?
Well, you know, you hit the New York Times
and your email and your calendar
and you kind of get your shit together.
I just do all that on my phone.
Okay.
你喜欢在电脑上做的循环。这很好。等等。你的电脑循环是什么？嗯，你知道，你点击《纽约时报》和你的邮件和你的日历，你有点把你的事情整理好。我只是在手机上做所有这些。好的。
So I'm probably actually on my phone
more than people that have a computer.
But see, what I'm picturing here
is that you've got no reason or excuse
to get up out of the pillows.
Correct.
You're still in the feathers.
You reach over, you grab your phone.
所以我可能实际上比有电脑的人更多地使用手机。但看，我在这里想象的是，你没有理由或借口从枕头里起来。正确。你还在羽毛里。你伸手，你抓起你的手机。
I'm just in a pile of feathers.
You sleep in a pile of feathers for real.
What an angel.
I'm down with that.
You had a nice desktop.
You could get out and into the living room and join the world.
Get yourself a desktop.
我只是在一堆羽毛里。你真的睡在一堆羽毛里吗？真是个天使。真是个天使。我同意这一点。你有个漂亮的台式机。你可以出来走进客厅，加入这个世界。给自己买台台式机。
This is a great opportunity for a new segment I'm calling.
J.B., walk us through it.
You don't want to follow my morning.
All right, so Emma, which one of your rad projects
are we going to talk about today?
There's so many, okay, so you answer that first.
I don't know.
Which one would you like to talk about?
这是一个很好的机会，可以进行一个新的环节，我称之为。J.B.，带我们过一遍。你不想跟随我的早晨。好吧，那么艾玛，我们今天要谈论你的哪些激进项目？有太多了，好吧，所以你先回答那个。我不知道。你想谈论哪一个？
I want to talk about our childhood.
I want to talk about your birthday last week.
Happy birthday.
What?
Thank you so much.
Yes.
Thank you.
Are we allowed to guess the age?
我想谈谈我们的童年。我想谈谈你上周的生日。生日快乐。什么？非常感谢。是的。谢谢。我们被允许猜年龄吗？
Can we guess the age?
Oh, this might be mean, but sure.
Go ahead.
No, no, no, no.
How about, I'm going to go with 24.
25.
Will?
I'm going to get real.
我们可以猜年龄吗？哦，这可能很刻薄，但当然。去吧。不，不，不，不。怎么样，我要猜24岁。25岁。威尔？我要来真的。
Yeah, be real.
I'm not going to play some.
Will and I worked together when I was, I think,
Yes, that's true.
Really?
That was a long time ago.
That is true.
He's going to win then.
是的，来真的。我不会玩什么……威尔和我一起工作时，我当时，我想，是的，那是真的。真的吗？那是很久以前的事了。那是真的。那他会赢。
So wait, then wait.
Then, Sean, you go next.
Okay.
I was going to say late 20s.
That's very cute, Sean, and sweet.
True, I really don't know.
Are you truly north of 30?
I'm north of 30.
所以等等，那么等等。那么，肖恩，你接着来。好的。我本来要说20多岁末。那很可爱，肖恩，而且很甜。真的，我真的不知道。你真的超过30岁了吗？我超过30岁了。
Oh, she is 37.
Come on.
35.
You're the closest by far.
Wow, really?
35.
You don't look 37.
I was just guessing based on what the information.
哦，她37岁了。得了吧。35岁。你是最接近的，差远了。哇，真的吗？35岁。你看上去不像37岁。我只是根据信息猜测的。
Okay, well.
Sure, well.
Okay.
No, no.
That's true.
We did.
We did work here.
That was a long time ago.
好的，好吧。当然，好吧。好的。不，不。那是真的。我们确实。我们确实在这里工作过。那是很久以前的事了。
I know.
What was the job?
Do you remember?
It was called.
The rocker.
You didn't.
Wait, the rocker I still need to see.
我知道。那是什么工作？你还记得吗？它叫。《摇滚青春》（The Rocker）。你没有。摇滚青春。等等，摇滚青春我还需要看。
And what was the other one I said I needed to see the other day?
Hot Rod.
All right.
Well, let's not go through mine.
Emma, go tell everybody who is in the rock.
Nobody's seen it.
Who is in the rocker?
I know.
还有我前几天说我需要看的另一个是什么？《热血大叔》（Hot Rod）。好吧。嗯，我们别过我的了。艾玛，去告诉大家谁在摇滚青春里。没人看过它。谁在摇滚青春里？我知道。
The cast is pretty hilarious.
It was Rayne Wilson.
Yeah.
Jason Sedakis.
Yep.
You.
Bradley Cooper.
Yep.
演员阵容相当搞笑。是雷恩·威尔森。是的。杰森·苏戴奇斯。是的。你。布莱德利·库珀。是的。
Fred Armisen.
Yep.
You?
Who directed this?
A guy named Peter Catanio who directed the full Monty.
Peter Catanio.
Yeah, yeah.
And...
弗莱德·阿米森。是的。你？谁导演的？一个叫彼得·卡塔尼奥的人，他导演了《光猪六壮士》。彼得·卡塔尼奥。是的，是的。还有……
John Glazer.
Oh, yeah.
The great John Glazer.
Who did Hot Rod?
Who directed Hot Rod?
That wasn't Yormo, was it?
No, Akiva.
Gotcha.
约翰·格拉泽。哦，是的。伟大的约翰·格拉泽。谁拍了《热血大叔》？谁导演了《热血大叔》？那不是Yormo，是吗？不，阿基瓦。明白了。
But the cast was pretty...
It was pretty wild.
Yeah, we were in Toronto.
We were in Toronto.
And I feel like you weren't there for that long.
I was there for a couple months.
I was there for a week maybe.
And what kind of part were you playing, Emma?
但演员阵容相当……相当狂野。是的，我们在多伦多。我们在多伦多。而且我觉得你没在那儿待太久。我在那儿待了几个月。我在那儿待了一周，也许。你演的是什么角色，艾玛？
Well, I was playing the bass in a band that was fronted by.
It was sort of a school of rock adjacent.
Would you say, Will.
Yeah, I would.
Kind of story.
Willie, what were you planned?
Oh, I played the lead singer of a hair band.
True story.
嗯，我在一个乐队里弹贝斯，主唱是。这有点像《摇滚校园》的邻居。你会这么说吗，威尔。是的，我会。那种故事。威利，你演什么？哦，我演一个发型乐队的主唱。真实故事。
You got to check it out.
And Bradley was the guitarist and Fred was the bassist.
Yep.
But it was fun.
But yeah, I mean, you have not, I'm trying to think,
you just have not stopped working and doing awesome stuff
since the moment I became aware of you.
You've just been like consistently just doing cool thing after cool thing,
你得去看看。布莱德利是吉他手，弗莱德是贝斯手。是的。但这很有趣。但是的，我的意思是，你没有，我在想，自从我认识你那一刻起，你就没有停止过工作和做很棒的事情。你一直都在持续地做一件又一件很酷的事情，
great film after great film.
It's pretty remarkable.
Not a lot of people.
And rare.
Basically, you haven't done anything as shitty as the rocker since the rocker
is what Will is saying.
I've done way worse movies
than the rocker since the rocker.
一部又一部伟大的电影。这非常了不起。没多少人。而且罕见。基本上，自从《摇滚青春》以来，你没做过任何像《摇滚青春》那么烂的东西，这就是威尔想说的。自从《摇滚青春》以来，我拍过比《摇滚青春》烂得多的电影。
Oh my God.
Subjective.
Well, I think, maybe.
It is great.
It is good.
Let's not go too deep through the IMDB or whatever.
I met you once very briefly.
You were so kind years and years ago.
哦，天哪。主观。嗯，我想，也许。它很棒。它很好。我们别太深入IMDB之类的了。我见过你一次，非常短暂。你多年前非常友善。
Blah, blah, blah, you never remember.
I think it was at SNL.
But I was like, oh, my God, that's Emma Stone.
And then, so when I did my research for today,
I didn't know that your name was Emma Lee.
I want to know these guys,
I know why it's called Emma,
but I want you to tell these guys
巴拉巴拉，你永远记不住。我想是在《周六夜现场》。但我当时想，哦，天哪，那是艾玛·斯通。然后，所以当我为今天做研究时，我不知道你的名字是艾玛·李。我想知道这些家伙，我知道为什么叫艾玛，但我想要你告诉这些家伙
why you change it to Emma.
And then I also want to know about your dog bakery thing
that you worked at
because I have a friend who lives in Arizona
who is a company, it's a dog poop company.
She picks up poop, dog poop for,
you just call her and she picks up dog poop.
But it was in Scottsdale.
为什么你把它改成艾玛。然后我还想知道关于你工作的那个狗狗面包店的事情，因为我有个朋友住在亚利桑那州，是一家公司，是一家狗屎公司。她捡狗屎，狗屎，为了，你只要给她打电话，她就去捡狗屎。但那是在斯科茨代尔。
Oh, that's where I'm from.
I know.
That's amazing.
Well, my name was taken.
Have you noticed like there's been less dog poop around when you go home?
You know, now that you mention it.
You can't gauge how Sean's friends.
I mean, it used to be absolutely.
哦，那是我家乡。我知道。那太棒了。嗯，我的名字被占用了。你有没有注意到当你回家时狗屎变少了？你知道，既然你提到了。你无法衡量肖恩的朋友。我的意思是，它过去绝对是……
everywhere just piles that way.
But her gig, her gig is just, she's just a freelance.
She just goes around town.
Freelance poop.
And she's looking for just spare poop that's unclaimed and unbipped up.
You call it up if you don't want to pick up your dog poop.
It's called Poop Patrol.
Sherry's poop poop.
到处都是堆积如山。但她的工作，她的工作只是，她只是个自由职业者。她只是在城里到处跑。自由职业捡屎。她在寻找那些无人认领和没被捡走的闲置狗屎。如果你不想捡你的狗屎，你就打电话给她。它叫“捡屎巡逻队”。雪莉的捡屎。
Who's compensating her?
The city?
Her clients.
People who don't want poop in their lawn, man.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm, I'm confused.
Wait.
So you call her just, so you just let your dogs kind of run free on your own lawn like all week.
谁在付钱给她？城市？她的客户。那些不想在草坪上有狗屎的人，伙计。是的。等等，我，我困惑了。等等。所以你只是打电话给她，所以你只是让你的狗在你自己草坪上自由跑，就像整个星期一样。
And then Poop Patrol comes.
Oh, like a gardener.
You come up.
That's right.
A gardener comes over, picks up the poop.
Yeah.
Like instead of blowing the leaves and stuff,
there's a poop.
然后捡屎巡逻队就来了。哦，就像园丁一样。你过来。没错。园丁过来，捡起狗屎。是的。就像不用吹树叶之类的，有狗屎。
Wow.
I don't know.
30 jokes in there?
I didn't know where to.
Well, that's kind of why I brought it up.
It's such a funny job.
You take a tight five and gather them and then come back to us.
哇。哇。我不知道。里面有30个笑话？我不知道该去哪儿。嗯，这就是我提起它的原因。这是一份如此有趣的工作。你花五分钟整理一下，然后回到我们这儿。
But wait, a dog bakery.
You worked at a dog bakery when you were a teenager?
Yeah, okay.
I worked a dog bakery when I moved to L.A.
when I was 15,
called Three Dog Bakery at the Farmers Market.
At the Grove?
但等等，狗狗面包店。你十几岁时在狗狗面包店工作过？是的，好吧。我15岁搬到洛杉矶时在一家狗狗面包店工作，叫“三只狗面包店”，在农夫市场。在格罗夫？在格罗夫？
I used to go there.
You worked there?
Yes.
Oh my God.
I mean, not for long, for like maybe six months.
Wow.
So, wait.
Johnny, this was pre-Ricky?
我过去常去那儿。你在那儿工作过？是的。哦，天哪。我的意思是，没待多久，大概六个月。哇。所以，等等。强尼，这是瑞奇之前吗？
Yeah, this was years ago, years and years ago.
This was why I was 15, 20 years ago.
Yeah, that's when I had my two other dogs.
I used to go there to shop for them.
Do you think that we ever ran into each other then?
Probably.
Maybe.
是的，这是几年前，几年前的事了。这是我15岁的时候，20年前。是的，那时我有我的另外两只狗。我过去常去那儿为它们购物。你觉得我们那时遇到过吗？可能。也许。可能。
Huh.
I think word would have gotten out that,
Will and Grace's Sean Hayes was there.
I think you're right.
I think I would have told everybody.
Guaranteed.
You probably should guarantee.
Oh my God.
嗯。我想如果《威尔和格蕾丝》的肖恩·海耶斯在那儿，消息早就传开了。我想你是对的。我想我会告诉每个人的。保证。你可能应该保证。哦，天哪。
Okay, so I must not have been working those hours.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Back to the show.
Tell these guys why you change your name from Emily to Emma.
Well, it was originally my name was taken at Screen Actress Guild.
Right.
When I got my card when I was 16.
好的，所以我一定没在那些时间工作。我们马上回来。好的。回到节目。告诉这些家伙你为什么把名字从艾米丽改成艾玛。嗯，最初我的名字在演员工会里被占用了。对。我16岁拿到卡的时候。
So it was an Emily Stone.
Wow.
And so I originally changed it.
to Riley because what do you tell a 16 year old
that they can just change their name?
Right.
You pick a cool name.
And so I was like, I'll be Riley.
所以那是艾米丽·斯通。哇。所以我最初改了它。改成莱利，因为你告诉一个16岁的人他们可以改名字？对。你选个酷名字。所以我当时想，我就叫莱利。
Right.
You could have changed it to Emma
middle name Lee.
Emma Lee Stone.
Right?
That you, that...
I don't know if I could pull off being a three-nameer.
Fuck, is there any way you could call her 20 years ago?
对。你可以把它改成艾玛，中间名李。艾玛·李·斯通。对吧？你，那个……我不知道我能不能驾驭三个名字。操，20年前有没有办法叫她？
Could you call me 20 years ago really quick?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just one second.
We'll pause.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we'll just...
That is a real thing, though, right?
That is a real thing, though,
你能20年前快速叫我一下吗？是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。就一秒钟。我们暂停。是的，是的，是的。然后我们只是……但那是一件真实的事情，对吧？那是一件真实的事情，对吧，
all people who change their names
because of Sack,
because there's already somebody...
Yeah.
Michael J. Fox, I think,
was because there was already a Michael Fox, right?
One of the great ones is,
isn't...
所有因为演员工会而改名的人，因为已经有某人了……是的。迈克尔·J·福克斯，我想是因为已经有一个迈克尔·福克斯了，对吧？其中一个伟大的例子是，不是……
I feel like Michael Keaton is Michael Douglas.
Oh, wow.
Oh, really?
And he changed his last name to Keaton
because Michael Douglas was Michael Douglas.
I just learned Albert Brooks's real name
is Albert Einstein.
I did not know that.
我觉得迈克尔·基顿是迈克尔·道格拉斯。哦，哇。哦，真的吗？他把姓改成了基顿，因为迈克尔·道格拉斯就是迈克尔·道格拉斯。我刚知道阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯的真名是阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。我不知道。
No.
swear to God.
That's unbelievable.
His brother was Bob Einstein,
you know, Super Dave Osborne.
That was Bob Einstein
and that's Albert's brother.
不。对上帝发誓。对上帝发誓。那太不可思议了。他哥哥是鲍勃·爱因斯坦，你知道，超级戴夫·奥斯本。那是鲍勃·爱因斯坦，那是阿尔伯特的哥哥。
But anyway, Emily to Emma.
Emily to Emma.
Because...
Well, because you're trying to get to the spice girls' rap.
Yes.
You should change your name to Albert Einstein
because that was free.
That's true.
但无论如何，艾米丽到艾玛。艾米丽到艾玛。因为……嗯，因为你在试图接近辣妹合唱团的节奏。是的。你应该把你的名字改成阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦，因为那是免费的。那是真的。
That one's free now.
Not being used anymore.
Wait, so you went to Emma.
I went to Emma because growing up,
I was an enormous...
I mean, still to this day I am,
but an enormous...
an enormous, sorry I'm slurring.
那个现在免费了。不再被使用了。等等，所以你改成了艾玛。我改成了艾玛，因为成长过程中，我是一个巨大的……我的意思是，直到今天我还是，但一个巨大的……一个巨大的，抱歉我在口齿不清。
I've been up for four days.
You need to take a nap.
Yeah, I got to take a nap.
I was a huge Spice Girls fan.
And there was Emma, who was Baby Spice.
No way.
Crazy about her.
Yeah.
我已经四天没睡了。你需要小睡一会儿。是的，我得小睡一会儿。我是辣妹合唱团的超级粉丝。那里有艾玛，她是宝贝辣妹。不会吧。为她疯狂。是的。
I love that.
When I was in, you know, like second or third grade,
I asked the teacher to call me Emma,
but it didn't ever stick.
But then I had the chance to do it permanently.
And here I am.
I love that.
Have you met the Spice Girls since?
我喜欢那个。当我在，你知道，比如二年级或三年级时，我让老师叫我艾玛，但它从来没坚持下来。但后来我有机会永久地改了它。现在我在这儿。我喜欢那个。你后来见过辣妹合唱团吗？
I have.
Does she know that?
How is that?
girls now. I think she does
because she gave me a really special t-shirt
that she had signed. It was like from one
Emma to another kind of thing. It was pretty cool.
Did you keep it together or did you just totally
见过。她知道吗？那是怎样的？现在的女孩们。我想她知道，因为她给了我一件她签名的特别T恤。就像从一个艾玛到另一个艾玛的那种。那很酷。你保持冷静了，还是你完全
fan out of them? I did not keep it together at all, at all.
But I will say, the night before
I met them, we were going to their concert
in England when they
when they, you know, had done,
they did like a reunion tour a couple years ago
in 2019 and the night
before I went to a
成了她们的粉丝？我一点也没保持冷静，一点也没。但我会说，我见到她们的前一天晚上，我们正要去英国看她们的演唱会，当她们，你知道，做过，她们几年前在2019年做过重组巡演，前一天晚上我去了一个
party at somebody's
house and the
magician David Blaine was there.
Okay.
And he did a,
just an astounding trick.
You know, he did this card trick,
and then it was this whole thing.
某人家里的派对，魔术师大卫·布莱恩在那儿。好的。他做了一个，只是一个惊人的戏法。你知道，他做了这个纸牌戏法，然后那是整个事情。
It was an illusion, an illusion, if you want.
And it was like, and he pulled up his phone,
and the card was reflected in a picture on someone's,
you know, in the glasses of someone on a boat,
and it was this crazy thing.
And I got so excited,
now this is the tale's oldest time
because I'm about to tell you a story from yesterday as well.
这是一个幻觉，一个幻觉，如果你想的话。就像，他拿出他的手机，牌反映在某人的照片里，你知道，在船上某人的眼镜里，那是件疯狂的事情。我太兴奋了，现在这是老掉牙的故事，因为我也要告诉你昨天的一个故事。
Whoa.
I got so excited.
that I ran.
I was like,
I can't stand it
because I'm such a big fan of magic
and I couldn't stand it
and I ran
哇。我太兴奋了。以至于我跑了。我当时想，我受不了了，因为我是魔术的超级粉丝，我受不了了，我跑了
and I was wearing these
healed boots
and I slipped on the wood floor
this is the night before the Spice Girls concert
slipped,
my arm went back out behind me
and I broke my fucking shoulder.
When was this?
我穿着这些高跟靴子，我在木地板上滑倒了，这是辣妹演唱会的前一天晚上，滑倒了，我的手臂向后伸到我身后，我摔断了我他妈的肩膀。这是什么时候？
No blame responsible for that.
The summer of 2019
so the next day I'm supposed to go
to the Spice Girls concert
and I was like
there is no way on Earth
I'm missing this.
So we got in England one of these, you know,
没有责怪任何人对此负责。2019年的夏天，所以第二天我应该去辣妹演唱会，我当时想，地球上没有任何东西能阻止我。所以我们在英国弄到了一个，你知道，
things from boots, the drugstore,
this little sling.
And I hadn't even gotten an x-ray yet.
And I went and I was in so much pain
that actually meeting the spice girls
under those circumstances was probably better
so I couldn't do that in front of them instead.
And your excitement was so tempered by the pain you were in.
从药店买的东西，这个小吊带。我甚至还没拍X光片。我去了，我当时非常痛苦，以至于在那种情况下见到辣妹可能更好，所以我不能在她们面前那样做。而且你的兴奋被你的痛苦冲淡了。
It was so tempered by the pain that I was like,
it's amazing to meet you guys.
Oh my God.
Like it was so brutal.
It was broken in two places.
And then yesterday,
I have bone density issues, that's clear, because I broke my toe yesterday.
No.
它被痛苦冲淡了，以至于我当时想，见到你们真是太棒了。哦，天哪。就像它太残酷了。它在两个地方断了。然后昨天，我有骨密度问题，这很清楚，因为我昨天摔断了脚趾。不。
I did.
Are you kidding?
Doing what?
On what?
Getting out of the shower.
Yeah.
Well, you should have been lying down in the shower.
What do you mean getting out of?
我真的断了。你在开玩笑吗？做什么？在什么上？从淋浴间出来。是的。好吧，你应该躺在淋浴间里。什么叫从……出来？
I know.
You accidentally, you stubbed it on something?
I slammed it into something, and now it's completely black and blue and like all messed up.
It's all day.
And you're sick, and you showed up for us today.
God bless you.
Yeah, how did you not cancel?
It's a dream.
我知道。你意外地，你把它撞到什么东西上了？我把它猛地撞到什么东西上，现在它完全青一块紫一块，就像全搞砸了。整天都是。而且你生病了，你今天还为我们露面。上帝保佑你。是的，你怎么没取消？这是一个梦想。
This is incredible.
Are you kidding?
I'm sitting on a computer with headphones.
This is lovely.
Half of one of those excuses would have made me cancel this thing.
God, I was just thinking, I would give.
I was so excited for this.
I would give anything for improved bone density.
这太不可思议了。你在开玩笑吗？我正坐在电脑前戴着耳机。这很可爱。那些借口中的一半都会让我取消这个东西。天哪，我刚才在想，我会给。我对此太兴奋了。我会为了改善骨密度付出任何代价。
Yeah.
Sorry, just sidebar.
Sidebar.
We need to take, what is it, Boniva or something.
Yeah, Boniva.
There's some pill to help our bone density.
But I've broken seven bones.
Before I was 30, I broke seven bones.
是的。抱歉，只是侧边栏。侧边栏。我们需要服用，那是什么，Boniva还是什么的。是的，Boniva。有一些药片可以帮助我们的骨密度。但我摔断了七根骨头。30岁之前，我摔断了七根骨头。
Emma.
Isn't that crazy?
Wow.
So then you seriously looked into this.
You seriously do have bone density issues?
There's an endocrinologist was like,
we got to talk about this.
Like something's up with you.
艾玛。那不疯狂吗？哇。所以你认真研究过这个。你真的有骨密度问题吗？有个内分泌学家就像，我们得谈谈这个。就像你身上出了什么事。
Right.
And did he come up with anything?
Just that I need to take a lot of vitamin D and calcium
and do apparently weight-bearing exercises,
like heavy lifting is what creates more bone density.
Well, you could just drink milk and eat like dumplings from chin-chin like Sean.
Jesus.
He has a glass of milk four times a day.
对。他想出什么了吗？只是我需要摄入大量的维生素D和钙，并且显然要做负重运动，比如举重是创造更多骨密度的东西。好吧，你可以只喝牛奶，吃像肖恩那样的Chin-Chin饺子。耶稣。他每天喝四次牛奶。
No, I have a glass of milk with dinner every night.
No, you don't.
I really do.
You're joking.
Why not? It's good for you.
That's Chris.
It's good for you.
It's vitamin Z.
不，我每天晚餐喝一杯牛奶。不，你没有。我真的喝。你在开玩笑。为什么不？这对你有好处。那是克里斯。这对你有好处。那是维生素Z。
Will you sit at dinner drinking a glass of milk?
Yeah, I saw it a week ago.
I just, I just stopped.
Are you just doing it to be adorable or you really enjoy it?
No, this is what he does.
No, I, I know why.
Like leaving a beaver.
You know why because.
你晚餐时坐着喝一杯牛奶？是的，我一周前看到的。我只是，我只是停下来。你只是为了可爱才这么做，还是你真的喜欢它？不，这就是他做的。不，我，我知道为什么。就像离开海狸。你知道为什么，因为。
He lives like he's in the 50s.
It's incredible.
12-year-old in the 50s.
Because water's too boring and soda has too much sugar.
so I just drink milk.
Well, you know, they have zero sugar soda now.
I'm not into it.
So, listen, I want to sit,
他活得就像在50年代。这太不可思议了。50年代的12岁小孩。因为水太无聊了，苏打水糖分太多。所以我只喝牛奶。好吧，你知道，他们现在有零糖苏打水。我不感兴趣。所以，听着，我想坐，
by the way, since we're on medical stuff.
I wish this was just a gallon of milk that I was sitting out.
That'll be so fascinating.
Wait, but is it true?
Because you have one of those cool, like,
million billion dollar voices, too.
Is it true that you, first of all,
didn't know you had asthma
顺便说一句，既然我们在谈论医疗方面的东西。我希望这只是一加仑我坐着喝的牛奶。那会非常迷人。等等，但那是真的吗？因为你也有那种很酷的，比如百万亿的声音，对吧？这是真的吗，首先，你不知道你有哮喘
until you had an asthma attack
while filming EZA, which I read?
And the other thing is,
did you really have a condition
when you were a baby
because you cried too much
and the major voice.
Is that true?
直到你在拍摄EZA时哮喘发作，我读到的？还有另一件事，你婴儿时真的有某种状况，因为你哭得太多，导致了主要的声音。那是真的吗？
Yeah.
Because you were colicky
that gave you a raspy voice.
Like extremely colloquy
for five months.
What colic?
Can you imagine?
Now having a kid,
是的。因为你肠绞痛了五个月。什么绞痛？你能想象吗？现在有了孩子，
I cannot imagine
having a colicky baby
to that extent.
Five months.
What does that mean colloquy?
Collic is apparently
a condition
where your stomach
我无法想象有一个那么严重的肠绞痛婴儿。五个月。肠绞痛是什么意思？肠绞痛显然是一种你的胃
is killing you.
Like you're in a lot of pain.
It's like everything I can talk about
is just my medical.
No,
Oh, I know. It's fascinating.
But here's what I think it is.
It is the intestines or part of the GI track that is still developing and unkinking itself.
让你痛不欲生的状况。就像你非常痛苦一样。好像我能谈论的一切都只是我的医疗状况。不，哦，我知道。这很迷人。但我认为它是这样的。它是肠道或消化道的一部分，还在发育和舒展。
And there is a kink in the hose that is not, it still needs to grow to release itself.
And it takes a couple of weeks.
And the babies are miserable.
Miserable.
So it was like if I was awake, I was screaming myself hoarse every day.
And I think it was very, very traumatizing for my parents.
I see.
You know what's good for bone densities,
软管里有一个扭结，它还没有，它还需要生长才能自我释放。这需要几个星期。婴儿们非常痛苦。非常痛苦。所以就像如果我醒着，我每天都会哭到嗓子嘶哑。我认为这对我的父母来说非常、非常令人创伤。我明白了。你知道什么对骨密度有好处吗，
those, the astronauts,
you know that thing,
the power plate thing that vibrates,
that's supposed to be good for bone density.
Oh, thanks, well.
Isn't that kind of a 50s thing too?
Yeah.
A little belt around you that sheds?
那些，宇航员，你知道那个东西吗，那个会振动的力量板，据说对骨密度有好处。哦，谢谢，好吧。那不是50年代的东西吗？是啊。你身上系着的一条能减肥的小带子？
I read it once over a glass of milk.
I was trying to.
I want to know, let's get to the career stuff
because it's really interesting to me.
Okay, great.
Wait, how old, no, hang on,
how old's your baby?
Let's just do it quick.
我喝着牛奶读过一次。我试着。我想知道，让我们谈谈职业方面的事情，因为这对我来说真的很有趣。好的，太棒了。等等，多大，不，等等，你的孩子多大了？我们快点说吧。
How old are you?
Two and a half.
Aw, sweet.
Boy, girl.
Girl.
Oh, sweet.
I didn't know that.
你多大了？两岁半。两岁半。啊，真可爱。男孩，女孩。女孩。哦，真可爱。我不知道。
That's so fantastic.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
With your husband who you met at S&L?
Did you meet him in S&L?
Really?
Dave McCarrie?
那太棒了。恭喜。非常感谢。是啊。和你丈夫，你们是在《周六夜现场》认识的吗？你们是在《周六夜现场》认识的吗？真的吗？戴夫·麦卡里？
Yeah.
And is he, what does he do with S&L?
He was a writer-director there for about five years.
Oh, nice.
Doing digital shorts.
And you met him there?
I met him there, yeah.
But we had a bunch of mutual friends, so, yeah.
是啊。他是，他在《周六夜现场》做什么？他在那里当了大约五年的编剧兼导演。哦，不错。做数字短片。你们是在那里认识的？我在那里认识他的，是的。但我们有一群共同的朋友，所以，是的。
So great.
I love that.
I feel like I was there that week, too.
Although you probably hosted a few times.
I remember, I remember being there once when you were hosting,
and I was just like,
Guys, wait, hold on.
I'm going to host on December 2nd.
太棒了。我喜欢这个。我觉得我那周也在那里。虽然你可能主持过几次。我记得，我记得有一次你在主持的时候我在那里，我当时就像，伙计们，等等，等一下。我要在12月2日主持。
I get to get my five-timers jacket.
No way.
I'm so excited.
I can't even stand it.
I'm like, I'm freaking out.
You're so good at it.
That's really, really cool.
Wait, so, Emma, you and Dave married in the pandemic,
我终于要拿到我的五次主持夹克了。不会吧。我太兴奋了。我简直无法忍受。我简直要疯了。你做得太好了。那真的很、真的很酷。等等，所以，艾玛，你和戴夫是在疫情期间结婚的，
and was that just because it was planned that way and you just kept it or you're like,
you know what, let's just do this now?
You were waiting for a pandemic, weren't you?
Didn't you guys say you wanted to get married, but let's wait for a pandemic to hit?
I read that somewhere.
I just trim the fat a little bit on the invite list.
Yeah.
You know, the week that I got married, I did open a refrigerator and the handle broke off and I got a black eye.
那是本来就计划好的，你们只是坚持下来了，还是你们觉得，你知道吗，我们现在就做吧？你们在等疫情，不是吗？你们没说你们想结婚，但让我们等疫情爆发吗？我在某处读到过。我只是精简了一下邀请名单。是啊。我结婚的那周，我确实打开了一个冰箱，把手断了，我得了一个黑眼圈。
Oh, my God.
And that's where it stops.
You know, I do need a helmet.
I need a helmet and extensive therapy.
You got this new show with Nathan Fielder.
I want to skip ahead.
I know she's your guest.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这就是结束的地方。你知道，我确实需要一个头盔。我需要一个头盔和广泛的治疗。你和内森·菲尔德有了这个新节目。我想跳过。我知道她是你的嘉宾。
Oh, yes.
But that looks really.
I know she's your guest, but I'll take this one.
It looks really fun.
First of all, he's great and not just because he's...
He's Canadian.
He's super funny.
You're super funny.
哦，是的。但这看起来真的。我知道她是你的嘉宾，但我会接这个。它看起来真的很有趣。首先，他很棒，不仅仅是因为他……他是加拿大人。他超级有趣。你超级有趣。
And when I first saw the ad for it, I was like,
these motherfuckers.
And then they got one of those safeties in there.
Yeah, they sure did.
Put a wig on him.
Took a boom out of his hand and said, go.
This is like a fucking,
this is like a fucking talent explosion.
当我第一次看到它的广告时，我就想，这些混蛋。然后他们在那里面放了一个安全装置。是的，他们确实放了。给他戴上假发。从他手里拿走吊杆，说，走。这就像一个他妈的，这就像一个他妈的才华大爆发。
Happening in one thing.
I'm so goddamn excited for this thing.
I'm so excited for this.
It's a wild ride.
Tell us about, how did that come to you,
to your orbit?
So Nathan and I have,
known each other through Dave and Dave's best friend Kyle Mooney have been...
发生在一件事里。我为这件事感到该死地兴奋。我对此感到非常兴奋。这是一次疯狂的旅程。告诉我们，那是怎么来到你身边的，来到你的轨道上的？所以内森和我，通过戴夫和戴夫最好的朋友凯尔·穆尼认识……
I love, we love, Calhouni.
Huge love company.
And they've been best friends since they were nine years old.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, and so Nathan knew Dave and Kyle well, and I got to know Nathan for a couple years.
And then, I think in 2020, 2019, maybe, Nathan called me and said that he and Benny Safdi
had come up with this kind of loose idea for a show based on...
something that Nathan had really experienced,
我爱，我们爱，凯尔·穆尼。非常爱凯尔·穆尼。他们从九岁起就是最好的朋友。哦，哇。是的，所以内森很了解戴夫和凯尔，我认识内森几年了。然后，我想在2020年，2019年，也许，内森打电话给我，说他和本尼·萨夫迪想出了这个关于……内森真正经历过的事情的节目的松散想法，
where someone had said that they curse him in a moment.
And he was like, this probably isn't true,
but he found that it haunted him.
Sure.
And they started coming up with this sort of premise of what would happen
if you're kind of going about your life
and they had this idea for this couple who is trying to create
their own HGTV show.
有人说他们在某一刻诅咒了他。他说，这可能不是真的，但他发现这困扰着他。当然。他们开始想出这种前提，如果你正在过你的生活会发生什么，他们对这对试图创建自己的HGTV节目的夫妇有了这个想法。
But early on,
the husband, a little girl says,
I curse you.
And if that hangs over the premise of this whole show
and how that evolves and kind of makes them go crazy,
whether it's, you know, real or not.
And it just sort of spiraled out from there
and became this very intense show.
但在早期，丈夫，一个小女孩说，我诅咒你。如果这悬在这个节目的整个前提上，以及它是如何演变的，并让他们发疯，无论它是，你知道，真实的还是不真实的。它就从那里开始螺旋式上升，变成了这个非常激烈的节目。
It's really, it is a comedy, but it's kind of not a comedy.
Kind of dark.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's very, yeah, there's a lot going on there.
So it was, no, it was a blast.
And we were in New Mexico for like half of last year shooting that.
And say the title again?
The curse.
它确实是，它是一部喜剧，但它有点不是喜剧。有点黑暗。是啊。是啊。非常，是的，那里发生了很多事情。所以，不，这太棒了。去年我们有一半时间在新墨西哥州拍摄那个。再说一遍标题？《诅咒》。
Yeah, the curse.
I see posters for it everywhere.
And say the title one more time.
And just for the third time.
So, the curse.
I want to talk about poor things too, which is a movie that you have coming out.
The brilliant Yorgos Lanthamos?
I'm going to go see it this week.
是的，《诅咒》。我到处都能看到它的海报。再说一遍标题。就第三次。所以，《诅咒》。我也想谈谈《可怜的东西》，这是你即将上映的一部电影。才华横溢的欧格斯·兰斯莫斯？我这周要去看看。
You are?
Yeah.
Where are you going to see it?
I'm seeing it.
One of the screenings, because I'm going to be at those.
I'll see you there.
I just got a text for it, yeah.
Oh, great.
你要去吗？是啊。你要去哪里看？我要去看。其中一场放映，因为我会参加那些。到时候见。我刚收到一条短信，是的。哦，太棒了。
Was it me texting you to come to the screen?
Oh, he was you.
Do you go by Emma Stone?
Oh, shit, it is.
Yeah, interesting.
Yeah.
This is the second project with Yorgos?
Yes?
是我发短信让你来看放映的吗？哦，是你。你叫艾玛·斯通吗？哦，该死，是啊。是的，有趣。是的。这是与欧格斯的第二个项目？是吗？
It was technically the third because we made a short film at the beginning of 2020.
and then so but it was it was yes it was the second following one so brilliant
amazing we made another one in the meantime we made another one in new orleans last year no really
with with willam with william yeah willans and poor things yeah yeah so we're done two together
and so for my sister tracy um yorgos did the favorite the lobster just a bunch of great
great kill a sacred deer incredible dog tooth which is yeah so poor things so so did you develop
it did you find it like
Did you just get an offer?
严格来说是第三个，因为我们在2020年初拍了一部短片。然后，所以，但它是，是的，它是继一个之后的第二个，太棒了，太神奇了，我们在此期间又拍了一部，我们去年在新奥尔良又拍了一部，不，真的，和威廉，和威廉，是的，威廉和《可怜的东西》，是的，是的，所以我们一起做了两个，所以为了我的妹妹特雷西，嗯，欧格斯做了《宠儿》、《龙虾》，还有一堆伟大的，伟大的《圣鹿之死》，不可思议的《狗牙》，也就是，是的，所以《可怜的东西》，所以，你是开发它的吗？你是找到它的吗？就像你只是得到了一个报价？
Like, how did that come to?
So, Jorgos and I did the favorite in 2017,
and right as we were wrapping up the favorite,
he told me about this book
that he and Tony McNamara,
who was the writer of the favorite,
had optioned,
and they were working on adapting.
就像，那是怎么回事？所以，欧格斯和我在2017年做了《宠儿》，就在我们结束《宠儿》的时候，他告诉了我这本书，他和托尼·麦克纳马拉，也就是《宠儿》的编剧，已经获得了版权，他们正在努力改编。
And he just told me the premise of it,
and I was like, I beg of you,
I have to do this with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so for the next few years,
we worked on things
and started kind of putting it all together
and he asked me to be a producer on it, which was amazing.
他只是告诉了我它的前提，我就说，我求求你，我必须和你一起做这个。是啊，是啊，是啊。所以在接下来的几年里，我们研究了一些事情，开始把这一切放在一起，他让我成为它的制片人，这太棒了。
And so we kind of like assembled this team
and then at the end of 2021,
why do I keep saying all the dates?
Yeah, I don't know.
Because you're like Will, you have incredible recall on dates.
I do everything by date.
Really?
Month and year, yeah, yeah.
所以我们就像组建了这个团队，然后在2021年底，为什么我一直说所有的日期？是啊，我不知道。因为你就像威尔，你对日期有不可思议的记忆力。我按日期做所有事情。真的吗？月和年，是啊，是啊。
Me too. Everybody's birthdays?
Do you forget a birthday?
Can you forget a birthday once a birthday?
I can forget a birthday, but if you say like,
I can say like, oh yeah, like it was that time of year, that year.
It was this month.
March of 2023, he knows a difference between April of 21 and March of 24.
Maybe I function similarly.
我也是。每个人的生日？你会忘记生日吗？你能忘记生日吗？我可以忘记生日，但如果你说，我可以像说，哦，是的，就像那一年的那个时候。是这个月。2023年3月，他知道21年4月和24年3月的区别。也许我的功能类似。
Yeah.
But anyway.
Anyway, so we made it, we made it two years ago.
And yeah, it's just, it's, it's probably my favorite, my favorite thing I've ever gotten to do.
Really?
Yeah.
Wait, so with, you work all the time.
constantly, it seems like, which is great, and everybody can't get enough of you.
是啊。但无论如何。无论如何，所以我们做了它，我们两年前做了它。而且，是的，它只是，它，它可能是我做过的最喜欢的，我最喜欢的事情。真的吗？是啊。等等，所以，你一直都在工作。不断地，看起来是这样，这很好，每个人都对你爱不释手。
So when you go from set to set, other than your child, do you have like something, how do you set it up so it's home?
Or how do you set it up so it feels like, all right, I need to have at least this, this, this, and this in my trailer or this, this, and this with me?
What a fun question.
I'll tell you three things that always keep me company, no matter where I am.
Coke?
App.
Sorry?
Big plate of Coke.
所以当你从一个片场到另一个片场时，除了你的孩子，你有什么，你是怎么设置的，让它成为家？或者你是怎么设置的，让它感觉像，好吧，我需要在我的拖车里至少有这个、这个、这个和这个，或者这个、这个和这个和我在一起？多有趣的问题。我会告诉你三件无论我在哪里都一直陪伴我的事情。可乐？应用程序。抱歉？一大盘可乐。
She's got to get through it
I'm obsessed with the idea that I'm on Coke
just because I'm on cold medicine
Jason
Go with it
You know just suffering through this
On cold medicine
She's here on her on this
她得熬过去，我沉迷于我在喝可乐的想法，只是因为我在吃感冒药，杰森，随它去吧，你知道，只是忍受这个，在吃感冒药，她在这里，在她的，在这个
She's on a sick day
I have a broken
Broken foot
I'm near death
I know I can't believe it
No I apples and peanut butter
Really
Every day for a snack
她在请病假，我有一只骨折的脚，我快死了，我知道，我不敢相信，不，我苹果和花生酱，真的，每天当零食
I have apples and peanut butter
every day I have a Starbucks coffee.
Doesn't matter where I am.
Could be in the greatest coffee places in the world.
Europe, wherever.
Doesn't matter.
Find a Starbucks.
And what's your choice?
我每天都吃苹果和花生酱，我喝星巴克咖啡。无论我在哪里。可能是在世界上最好的咖啡店。欧洲，无论哪里。没关系。找一家星巴克。你选什么？
A coconut meisto.
Coconut.
No embarrassing to say.
What is it?
A coconut what?
Listen, they make you say meisto.
Which you know the Starbucks lingo
where they make you say these things.
椰子米斯托。椰子。不，说出来很尴尬。那是什么？椰子什么？听着，他们让你说米斯托。你知道星巴克的行话，他们让你说这些东西。
It's a venty coffee.
Just a regular filter coffee.
It's a large.
Drip coffee.
A large.
With steamed coconut.
milk. Okay. And that's the misto part? That's the meisto. That's what makes it a misto.
So that's not a latte? It's not a latte. No, because it's not espresso. So you have apple,
这是一杯大杯咖啡。只是一杯普通的过滤咖啡。这是一个大杯。滴漏咖啡。一个大杯。加蒸椰奶。好的。这就是米斯托的部分？这就是米斯托。这就是让它成为米斯托的原因。所以那不是拿铁？那不是拿铁。不，因为它不是浓缩咖啡。所以你有苹果，
by the way, I have peanut butter and rice cakes, always. Every day? Well, that's my treat. That's my
snack. That's your treat? Yeah, that's my snack. It felt like in a mid-after. Peanut butter and
rice cake? Oh, I love that. That's a healthy treat. It's not like you go and get all the
twizzlers from the crafty. Why do you guys go with just the apple or just the rice cake? Why do you need to spread all the
fatty nut butter
gives you a little hit of protein
and the big head of joy.
A lot of sugar.
顺便说一句，我一直有花生酱和米饼。每天？嗯，那是我的款待。那是我的零食。那是你的款待？是啊，那是我的零食。感觉就像在下午。花生酱和米饼？哦，我喜欢那个。那是一种健康的款待。不像你从工艺品那里拿所有的甘草糖。为什么你们只吃苹果或只吃米饼？为什么你需要涂抹所有的脂肪坚果酱给你一点蛋白质和巨大的快乐。很多糖。
I like the peanut butter with the apples.
It's delicious.
Sean, explain for, not for Tracy,
but for Jason, what joy is.
It's another kind of peanut butter.
Not for Tray.
Or no, that's Jiffy.
Emma, like
我喜欢花生酱配苹果。很好吃。肖恩，解释一下，不是为特雷西，而是为杰森，什么是快乐。那是另一种花生酱。不是为特雷西。或者不，那是吉夫。艾玛，就像
you were so fucking phenomenal
in the favorite, and you won for the favorite,
right?
No.
Yes, she did.
Nominated?
你在《宠儿》里真是太他妈的非凡了，你因为《宠儿》获奖了，对吧？不。是的，她获奖了。不。提名？是的，她获奖了。
No.
She was fantastic, though.
Thank you so much.
nominated. Wait, but what was that...
You won a nomination is what I meant.
Did you really not win? I can't remember.
You did win. Not for the... Not for the favorite, no.
Which one did you win for?
不。不过她很棒。非常感谢。提名。等等，但那是什么……我的意思是，你获得了一个提名。你真的没赢吗？我不记得了。你确实赢了。不是为了……不是为了《宠儿》，不。你是因为哪一部赢的？
La Lollah. Oh, that's right. Lala.
So I fucking love that movie, too.
God, you're so fucking good.
That's a truly embarrassing thing to have to sit here inside.
No.
Not for that one.
No, I want to know. I ask.
I want to know and try everything.
《爱乐之城》。哦，对了。拉拉。所以我他妈的也喜欢那部电影。天哪，你真是太他妈的好了。坐在这里说这些真是太尴尬了。不。不是那一部。不，我想知道。我问。我想知道并尝试一切。
But wait, the favorite was you were still...
My mom says I'm always a winner.
Yeah.
And always her first.
favorite.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
But was that, because when I've seen that movie,
when I watched that movie, I was like,
但等等，《宠儿》你还是……我妈妈说我永远是赢家。是啊。而且永远是她的第一。宠儿。是啊，没错，没错。但那是，因为当我看到那部电影时，当我观看那部电影时，我就想，
oh my God, this just looks like a colossal amount of work
that movie The Favorite.
Like, it just looks so grand and so massive.
That's just because a lot of it was in that fish eye lens.
That's what makes it look so grand.
All right.
You know what I mean?
That's a little trick of the trait.
哦，天哪，那部电影看起来真是巨大的工作量，《宠儿》。就像，它看起来那么宏大，那么庞大。那只是因为很多是在那个鱼眼镜头里。这就是让它看起来那么宏大的原因。好吧。你知道我的意思吗？那是交易的一点小把戏。
That was in England, yes.
That was in England.
And La La La Land was here in Los Angeles.
It was in L.A.
Yes.
Favorite is such a good movie.
I just wanted to, apart from the work that, you know,
these guys were so tired.
那是在英国，是的。那是在英国。《爱乐之城》是在这里，在洛杉矶。是在洛杉矶。是的。《宠儿》是一部很好的电影。我只是想，除了工作，你知道，这些人太累了。
But I, I, that movie was so good, Emma Stone.
Oh.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Was that one of the hardest things we've ever done that?
What's the hardest one you've ever done?
Oh, God.
Physically, emotionally, both, whatever.
但我，我，那部电影太好了，艾玛·斯通。哦。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。那是我们做过的最难的事情之一吗？你做过的最难的是什么？哦，天哪。身体上，情感上，两者都有，无论什么。
Lola had a bunch of stuff in it.
Oh, yeah.
You're going to learn.
The hardest thing I've ever done was on stage.
Yeah?
By far.
Sean loves stage stories.
I do.
《爱乐之城》里有很多东西。哦，是的。你会知道的。我做过的最难的事情是在舞台上。是吗？到目前为止。肖恩喜欢舞台故事。我喜欢。
You know I do.
Well, I've only done one professional stage show.
What went wrong?
Like 10 years ago.
Oh, you want a what went wrong story?
I want a bad theater story.
But here's the, I did cabaret.
And I only did it for three and a half months, which is so short by stage terms.
你知道我喜欢。嗯，我只做过一个专业的舞台表演。出了什么问题？就像10年前。哦，你想要一个出了什么问题的故事？我想要一个糟糕的剧院故事。但这是，我做了歌舞表演。我只做了三个半月，这在舞台术语中太短了。
But enough.
I thought, I truly going into it, I was so beyond excited.
It was probably the greatest experience in my life for the same reason.
And I was like, oh, you just do it at night.
And then you do two shows a day on Wednesday, and you do two on Saturday.
And then you're a home.
Your entire life is eaten.
And it is so hard.
但足够了。我以为，我真正进入它的时候，我太兴奋了。这可能是我一生中最伟大的经历，原因相同。我当时想，哦，你只是在晚上做。然后你周三做两场演出，周六做两场。然后你就回家了。你的整个生活都被吃掉了。而且这太难了。
You have to live like a monk.
Like there's nothing, or at least I did because I lose my voice and I sing.
And it was like, I've never experienced something that physically taxing as an actor.
Yeah.
It was.
It was unreal.
I'm sure.
Because that was the hardest.
你必须像僧侣一样生活。就像什么都没有，或者至少我做了，因为我失去了声音，我唱歌。这就像，我从来没有经历过作为演员身体上那么累的事情。是啊。它是。它是虚幻的。我相信。因为那是，最难的。
And when you, but did you anything go massively wrong?
Do you have any kind of night where you're just like, oh shit, my voice, nothing came out when I sang?
Oh, oh, yeah.
I mean, I had to take steroids multiple times.
No, yeah, no heart attacks in the house, thank God.
But that's, there are a lot of those stories.
But no, I, just to add to my, you know, things that are wrong with me, I'm extremely blind.
Blind, blind as a bat.
当你，但是你有什么大规模出错的事情吗？你有过那种你就像，哦，该死，我的声音，我唱歌时什么都没出来？哦，哦，是的。我的意思是，我不得不多次服用类固醇。不，是的，没有心脏病发作，谢天谢地。但是那是，有很多这样的故事。但是不，我，只是为了增加我的，你知道，我有问题的地方，我非常盲。盲，像蝙蝠一样盲。
Okay.
And I wear
Contacts for that
And
They both popped out of my eyes
While I was singing maybe this time
And there's
And it cuts to
好的。我戴着隐形眼镜。它们都从我的眼睛里弹出来了，当我在唱《也许这次》的时候。而且有，而且它切到
Really been reaching for a note
It cuts to it's really
Yeah I'm always reaching for those notes
I'm not a singer per se
And the
And the lights went dark
And you have to, you know, go off in the
In the blackout
真的在努力唱一个音符，它切到，它真的，是的，我总是努力唱那些音符，我本身不是歌手。而且，而且灯光变暗了。你必须，你知道，在停电中走出去。
And I couldn't see a thing
In the world
And I just went
and like slammed it.
It was terrible.
Getting off stage,
not being able to see it at all was.
That's terrifying.
我什么都看不见。在世界上，我只是走过去，就像猛击它。这太可怕了。下台，根本看不见，是。那太可怕了。
And then couldn't find the contacts, right?
They were on the floor.
Couldn't find it.
But no, I always bring spares.
I have to travel with spares.
Yeah.
It's very important.
It would be great if you did the rest of the play
然后找不到隐形眼镜，对吧？它们在地板上。找不到它。但没有，我总是带备用的。我必须带着备用的旅行。是的。这非常重要。如果你戴着眼镜做剩下的戏会很好，会很好。如果你戴着眼镜回来。是的，这一切都让我非常焦虑。但当你……我一直有一个恐惧，肖恩，在舞台上打嗝。是啊。哦，天哪，那是一个伟大的恐惧。你在舞台上打嗝过吗？
with glasses on, would have been great.
If you came back out with glasses.
Yeah, all of it gives me so much anxiety.
But when you...
I always had a fear, Sean, of getting hiccups on stage.
Yeah.
Oh my God, that's a great fear.
Have you had hiccups on stage?
没有，但我有一件事，我有，就像过敏。我能感觉到鼻后滴漏在后面。就在我必须唱歌之前，当你坠入爱河时你会得到什么？你知道，和克里斯和约翰一起。我当时简直就像，什么？哦，不。
No, but I had one thing where I had, like,
allergies.
and I could feel the post-nasal drip in the back.
And it was right before I had to sing,
what do you get when you fall in love?
You know, with Chris and John.
And I was literally like, what?
Oh, no.
就像永远。哦，天哪。这是最糟糕的。恐慌，眼泪，因为我不能咳嗽，但我必须表现得好像我是所有东西。它仍然，我有一百万年。好的，我正要告诉你们一些我认为你们不会喜欢的事情。
Like forever.
Oh, God.
It was the worst.
Panic, tears, because I couldn't cough,
but I had to act like I was everything.
It's still, I have a million years.
Okay, I'm about to tell you guys something
that I think that you're not going to enjoy.
我知道杰森不会喜欢这个。哦，不。当你得到时你做什么，我要问你们，我要去这里的小组。当你打嗝时你们做什么？你们有像万无一失的吗？我没有。
I know Jason's not going to enjoy this.
Oh, no.
What do you do when you get,
I'm going to ask you guys,
I'm going to go around to the panel here.
What do you guys do when you get the hiccups?
Do you have like a sure fire?
I don't have one.
我有一个护理。艾玛，我要先去。我有一个治愈方法，但人们告诉我我错了，但如果你做得对就不会，好吗？这是事情。是的，你不对人尖叫，对吧？这是盐。把你的手臂举过头顶。
I have a care.
Emma, I'm going to go first.
I have a cure, but people tell me that I'm wrong,
but not if you do it right, okay?
Here's the thing.
Yeah, you don't scream at people, do you?
This is the salt.
Put your arm up above your head.
左臂。把它举过头顶。嗯，只是因为我是右撇子。所以如果你是左撇子，你可以做。司机，不要这样做。你拿你的，如果你在开车就不要做。现在，拿水。你要，而且我说的是微小的，
Left arm.
Put it up above your head.
Well, just because I'm right-handed.
So if you're left-handed, you could do it.
Drivers, don't do this.
You take your, don't do it if you're driving.
Now, take water.
And you're going to, and I'm talking like tiny,
你走，吞咽，吞咽，吞咽，吞咽，吞咽，当你慢慢放下手臂时。嗯，什么都不会发生，因为我们都没有。你不是我们像白痴一样。我们都在做。嗯，我们只是在练习。听众们，我们都在做。我们在练习。
You go, swallow, swallow, swallow, swallow, swallow,
as you lower your arm slowly.
Well, nothing's going to happen because none of us.
You're not of us like idiots.
We're all doing it.
Well, we're just practicing.
Listeners, we're all doing it.
We're practicing.
我告诉你，它是百分之百有效的。我感觉不可思议。我感觉太棒了。你们做什么，肖恩或杰伊？什么都没有。我希望我有什么。我深吸一口气。试试这个。
I'm telling you, it is a hundred percent effective.
I feel incredible.
I feel amazing.
What do you guys do, Sean or Jay?
Nothing.
I wish I had something.
I take a deep breath.
Try this.
我有点让它感觉到它有点消失了。然后我屏住呼吸时喝水。它似乎有效。我从来没告诉过任何人。这是绝对真实的，我不敢相信我在说它。我们准备好了。任何时候我打嗝。
And I kind of let it feel it kind of go away.
and then I take water while I'm holding my breath.
It seems to work.
I've never told anybody this.
This is absolutely true,
and I can't believe I'm telling it.
We're ready.
Anytime I get the hiccups.
我记得有一次生动地，几年前，我们的伙伴埃德加·赖特，我们做了这个叫《不要》的东西，这就像一个假电影预告片，在中间，有一个双重账单，就像罗伯特·罗德里格兹的电影或什么，他做了这个假预告片，我做了声音。
And I remember one time vividly,
years ago, our buddy Edgar Wright,
we did this thing called Don't,
which was like a fake movie trailer between,
there was a double bill,
like a Robert Rodriguez film or whatever,
and he made this fake trailer,
and I did the voice.
无论如何，我记得去录制预告片的声音，因为我做不要甚至呼吸，不要甚至等等，我做了整个事情，对吧？它在西村的这个录音地方，做那个事情，我想我喝了苏打水，我打嗝了，因为我吸入了太多的空气，我就像，什么他妈的，这就是我学到它的地方，我就像，只是给我一秒钟，我只是必须，因为我像打嗝，你知道，试图录制，我走进浴室，哦，我把手指伸进喉咙，我让自己作呕，吐了一点。没了。
where anyway I remember going to record the trailer voice because I do don't even breathe
don't even blah blah blah I did this whole thing right it was in the West Village at this
recorded place and doing the thing and I'd had a soda I think and I got the hiccups because I was
taking in so much air and I was like what the fuck this is where I learned it and I was like
just give me a second I just got to because I'm like hiccuping on you know trying to record
and I go into the bathroom oh and I stick my finger down my throat and I make myself
gag and throw up a little bit.
Gone.
没了。没了。我明白了。我回来完成了。这就是我现在每次打嗝时所做的，我走，对不起。我明白了。那太恶心了。
I get it.
And I came back out and I finished.
And that's what I do every time
when I get the hiccups now, I go, excuse me.
I get it.
That is disgusting.
你只是在赌那会有效吗？有一个更好的方法，威尔。我不知道。它有效。你完全吐出来还是只是作呕？呃！嗯，这取决于我在哪里。你知道发生了什么。
Were you just gambling that that would work?
There's a better way, Will.
I don't know.
It works.
Do you fully throw up or do you just gag?
Ew!
Well, it depends on where I'm at.
You know what's going on.
你讨厌打嗝，以至于你会让自己呕吐？我讨厌打嗝。我会让自己。你只是在赌那会有效吗？还是你读过的一些东西？我只是在赌。我不知道。我只是做了。
You hate hiccups that you'll just make yourself puke?
I hate hiccups.
I will make myself on.
Were you just gambling that this would work?
Or is it something that you kind of read about?
I was just gambling.
I had no idea.
And I just did it.
哇，那是。嗯。我不知道这个。你的手臂或手腕或某个地方有纹身吗？我的手腕。我想看。一个非常、非常、非常糟糕的纹身。看这个。
Wow, that is.
Huh.
I did not know this.
You have a tattoo on your arm or your wrist or somewhere?
My wrist.
I want to see.
A very, very, very poorly done tattoo.
Look at this.
现在，这应该是，我只是想让你明白。这是基于一张用铅笔画的画。好的。它看起来像鸟脚。那看起来像铅笔吗？是仙人掌吗？它看起来像干草叉。它是鸟脚，而且它越来越多地流血。
Now, this was supposed to be, I just want you to understand.
This was based off of a drawing that was drawn with a pencil.
Okay.
It looks like bird feet.
Does that look like a pencil?
Is it a cactus?
It looks like a pitch fork.
It's bird feet and it bleeds out more and more.
每年。我13年前得到的，它一直在蔓延。20年后，这只会是什么样的半吊子纹身艺术家？你在法国监狱还是什么？我走进了一个14街的随机纹身店，我只是，是的。
every single year.
I got it 13 years ago
and it just keeps spreading.
In 20 years, this is just going to be
what kind of half-ass tattoo artist?
Were you in a French prison or something?
I went into just kind of a random tattoo
place on 14th Street and I was just, yes.
你为什么不咨询那个无袖的？你为什么不咨询那个无袖的？他可以为你联系一个伟大的纹身艺术家。现在我已经去了好的纹身艺术家那里，说，我可以把这个激光去掉吗？他们说，你的皮肤在那里太薄了，它可能看起来就像你被烧伤了。就像，它可能会更糟。
Why didn't you consult with the sleeveless one?
He could have hooked you up with a great tattoo artist.
And now I've gone to good tattoo artist and said,
can I get this lasered off and read down?
And they were like, your skin is so thin there
that it's probably just going to look like you're burnt.
Like, it might be worse.
哦，真的吗？所以等等。我不知道该怎么处理它。你妈妈也得到了同样的？我妈妈，我爸爸，我哥哥。我的意思是，它背后的故事太特别了，但它就像，而且他们的看起来都很棒，顺便说一句。真的吗？
Oh, really?
So wait.
I don't know what to do with it.
And your mom got the same one?
My mom, my dad, my brother.
I mean, the story behind it is so special,
but it was like, and theirs all look great, by the way.
Really?
因为他们都去了更好的纹身人那里。我是那个每天都要为工作遮盖它的人。而且它凸起来了。它真的。你不是和梭罗一起玩了一点吗？哦，我知道梭罗。是的。好的，所以他可以为你联系一个也许有更好针的人。
Because they all went to better tattoo people.
And I'm the one who's to cover it up for work every day.
And it's like raised up.
It's really.
Don't you hang out with Thoreau just a little bit?
Oh, I know Thoreau.
Yeah.
Okay, so he could have hook you up with somebody with maybe a better needle.
那时我不认识他。是啊，是啊。这是2010年。不过我喜欢你全家都有它。对贾斯汀有什么想法？这是2010年10月，威尔。你记得。我喜欢那个。
I didn't know him then.
Yeah, yeah.
This was 2010.
I love that your whole family has it, though.
Any thoughts on Justin?
This was October of 2010, Will.
You remember.
I love that.
我喜欢那个。顺便说一句，我之前没打算说，但是，你知道，当我们拍摄《摇滚者》时，是2007年6月。好的。我知道。那太疯狂了。我知道你知道。我知道你知道。那是，是的，杰森。
By the way, I wasn't going to say it before, but, you know, when we shot the rocker, it was June of 2007.
Okay.
I know.
That's so crazy.
I know you know.
That is, yeah, Jason.
提出了一个好观点。对梭罗有什么想法？顺便说一句，这是一个安全的，安全的空间。你能想到的任何伤人的话？我们引入的另一个环节。嗯，你知道，他患有湿疹。这就对了。他真的有吗？这就是为什么他不穿袖子，因为他很骄傲，他想展示它。这就对了。不，那不是
brought up a good point. Any thoughts on Thoreau?
And by the way, this is a safe, safe space.
Anything hurtful that you can think of?
Another segment we're introducing.
Well, you know, he suffers from eczema.
There we go. Does he really?
That's why he doesn't wear sleeves because he's proud
and he wants to show it. That's right. No, that's not
那不是真的。真的吗？他的湿疹在哪里？我不知道他是否真的患有湿疹。只是，你知道，我们有很多。我们有过护肤对话，正如你可以想象的那样，你知道？我们曾经在他的维基百科页面上写道，他在高潮时会哭。这是真的。有人把它拿下来了吗？他拿下来了。
that's not true. Really? Where's his ex-Rizzo?
I don't know if he really does suffer from Excema.
It's just, you know, we've had a lot. We've had skincare conversations,
as I'm sure you can imagine, you know?
We once put on his Wikipedia page that he cries when he orgasms.
It's true.
Did someone take it off?
He did.
他确实像晚了一个小时。我想他收到警报或什么了。坎摩尔知道如何像闯入某人的维基百科页面。也是知道怎么做的人不对。我喜欢那个。你们会在我的维基百科页面上放点什么吗？不要放那个。放点别的。
He did like an hour late.
I guess he got an alert or something.
Kimmel knows how to like break into someone's Wikipedia page.
The wrong person to know how to do it too.
I love that.
Will you guys put something on my Wikipedia page?
Don't put that one.
Put something different.
不，是的。我们会放吉米的脑子。我们要放贾斯汀·梭罗高潮时会哭。拜托。拜托。不要放那个。那会很有趣。那会很有趣，虽然。
No, yeah.
We'll put Jimmy's brain.
We're going to put cries when Justin Thoreau orgasms.
Please.
Don't put that.
It would be funny.
It would be funny, though.
我可以问关于像早期的，因为你有一个哥哥，对吧？我有一个弟弟。你和你哥哥亲近吗？非常，是的。他在这个行业吗？这是我们两个。不，不，他在一家科技公司工作。
Can I ask about like early,
because you have a brother, right?
I have a younger brother.
You close with your brother?
Very, yeah.
Is he in the business?
This is the two of us.
No, no, he works at like a tech company.
成长过程中，他感兴趣吗？他不太像，你做那个，我要去这边。一点也不。他踢足球。是的，家在哪里？你在哪里长大的？亚利桑那州斯科茨代尔。和便便一起？
And growing up, was he interested or no?
He was less like, you do that, I'm going to go over here.
Not at all.
He played football.
Yeah, where was home?
Where did you grow up?
Scottsdale, Arizona.
With the poop?
和便便一起。记得吗？记得早些时候吗？同样的对话。嗯？你谈了多久了？记得从之前吗？就像25。
With the poop.
Remember?
Remember earlier?
the same conversation.
Huh?
How long have you been talking?
Remember from before?
It was like 25.
你说了什么？你说了什么？从早些时候。还有好的想法，关于亚利桑那州的好感觉。你怀念那里吗？你还有家人在那里吗？是的，我还有家人在那里。关于亚利桑那州的事情是它太热了。
What did you say?
From earlier.
And good thoughts, good feelings about Arizona.
Do you miss it out there?
You still have family out there?
Yeah, I still have family out there.
The thing about Arizona is it's so hot.
它太压抑地热了。很难，你需要为那种热量而生。但我不是。这不是一种有趣的炎热。这根本不是一种有趣的炎热。就像每天120度。我们要结束了，我想，我想问你这个，因为我们要以一个行业商业问题结束。我喜欢商业，商业，商业问题。
It's so oppressively hot.
It's difficult to, you need to be built for that kind of heat.
And I'm not.
It's not a fun heat.
It's not a fun heat at all.
It's like 120 degrees daily.
And we're going to end, I want to, I wanted to ask you this because we're going to end on a industry business question.
I love a biz, a biz, a biz queue.
我喜欢商业。我喜欢这个行业。我喜欢热量。我喜欢嗡嗡声。当你，你知道，很多像你为《爱乐之城》赢得奥斯卡的人，他们，你太棒了，当之无愧。我喜欢那部电影。我喜欢你在里面的表现。你，很多赢的人，
I love the biz.
I love the business.
I love the heat.
I love the buzz.
When you, you know, a lot of people who win an Oscar like you did for La La Land, they, you were amazing, so deserved.
I loved that movie.
I loved you in it.
Did you, a lot of people who win,
有时它被称为一些演员的死亡诅咒。首先，我应该问，你们锁定了吗？在我给你这些之前？你们在《爱乐之城》上锁定画面了吗？因为你得了奥斯卡，太棒了。但有几件事。如果是我？我会再努力一点。
sometimes it's known as the curse of death with some actors.
First of all, I should ask, are you guys locked?
Before I give you these?
Are you picture locked on Lovelland?
Because you got the Oscar, great.
But a couple things.
Were it me?
I would try it a little harder.
我有一些笔记。是啊。为你高兴。我本来想说，你紧张吗？你有焦虑吗？你就像，哦，天哪，这太棒了，我赢得了奥斯卡。但你觉得，我不知道，很多时候一些赢得奥斯卡奖的演员，
I got some notes.
Yeah.
Good for you.
I was going to say, were you nervous?
Did you have anxiety?
You're like, oh my God, this is so great, I won the Oscar.
But did you feel like, I don't know,
a lot of times some actors who win Oscars,
你有点几年几年几年没见到他们了。你，你有关于像，该死，我赢了现在人们厌倦了我吗的焦虑？没有。没有人有那种感觉。没有。没有，但只是像，谁他妈的？什么样的疯子？肖恩，你为什么把那个放在世界上？
you kind of don't see them for a long, like years and years and years.
Were you, did you have anxiety about like, crap, I won now people are sick of me?
Nope.
Nobody felt that way.
No.
No, but just like, who the fuck?
What kind of psycho?
Sean, why do you put that out there in the world?
他们现在一定恨我了。好的。肖恩，你为什么告诉我们你的感受？不，不是。赢得了托尼奖。那是你走上舞台去拿托尼奖时说的吗？
They must hate me now.
Okay.
Sean, why did you tell us how you feel?
No, not.
won the Tony.
Is that what you were saying
when you were walking up your stage
to get the Tony?
检查。肖恩从我的名单上。我知道她对艾玛·斯通的感觉。那出来错了。我的意思是，你是否有关于像我不会工作的焦虑？人们就像人们一定认为
Check.
Sean off my list.
I know how she feels about in a stone.
That came out wrong.
What I meant was like
did you have anxiety about like
I'm not going to work?
People are like people must think
像哦，我们你成功了。我离开了，这是一个非常幸运的情况，因为我，我在拍摄《爱乐之城》时遇到了欧格斯，我在奥斯卡颁奖典礼后的第二天就去拍摄《宠儿》了。哦，那太棒了。所以这有点神奇
like oh we you made it.
I left that this was a very
lucky situation because I had
I met Yorgos while we were
filming La La Land and I left the day
after the Oscars to go shoot
the favorite. Oh, that's great.
So it was kind of amazing
因为第二天我就直接回去工作了，回到了……你在去地点的路上有时间重新谈判你的合同吗？是的，所以那是……我确实推迟了我的航班几个小时，只是为了打电话，只是为了给我的律师打电话，但是……顺便说一句，那只是重新开放了薪水部分。几个新的
because the next day I went right back to work
and was back in... Did you have time to renegotiate
your deal on your way to location?
Yes, so that was...
I did delay my flight for a couple hours
just to call, just to call my lawyer,
but... By the way, that was
reopened just a salary portion. A couple new
我想的交易点……不，但顺便说一句，那是一个巨大的赞美，我知道。我完全他妈的……好的，好的，好的。多少伟大的，因为你已经，你已经不是……提名，我肯定，一百万次，为了很多伟大的……很多伟大的奖项给我。你有一堆伟大的未使用的获奖感言吗？
deal points that I'd love to...
No, but by the way, that was a big compliment
is what I know. I'm completely fucking...
Okay, okay, okay. How many great, because you've been,
you've been not...
nominated, I'm sure, a million times for lots of great...
Lots of great awards for me.
Do you have a bunch of great unused acceptance speeches?
不，什么？不。我打赌你有。不。但我打赌你给了一些想法，一些尊重的时间和一些想法，关于你会站在那里说什么。你不是这些忘恩负义的人之一，如果我赢了，我赢了，我只会走上去即兴发挥。
No, what?
No.
I bet you do.
But I bet you give some thoughts, some respectful time and some thought to what you would say up
there.
You're not one of these ingrates that would just, if I win, I win, I'll just go up there
and wing it.
我打赌你有一些有趣的东西你说过。我的梦想是有一本像书，一本咖啡桌书，关于人们未使用的获奖感言。那是个好主意。那是个非常好的主意。那是个非常好的主意。也许你应该开始汇编那个。你必须是匿名的，不是吗？嗯。
I bet you've got some fun stuff that you said.
My dream is to have like a book, a coffee table book of people's unused acceptance speech.
That's a great idea.
That's a really good idea.
Maybe you should start compiling that.
You have to be anonymous though, wouldn't it?
Well.
对吧？那些有演讲的人？是的，因为我想那会是，但你如何做一个匿名的获奖感言？每个人都会知道它是谁，就像他们感谢的人。你本来要为《摇滚者》说什么？是的。如果你为《摇滚者》走上去，嗯，你会先感谢谁？可能只是威尔。
Right?
The people with the speeches?
Yeah, because I guess it would be, but then how do you do an anonymous acceptance speech?
Everyone would know who it was, like the people they're thanking.
What were you going to say for the rocker?
Yeah.
If you had gotten up there for the rocker, well, who would you think first?
Probably just will.
只是威尔。感谢你今天成为我们的嘉宾。谢谢你邀请我。不，但你被提名了……你被提名了《爱乐之城》，你赢了。你被提名了《宠儿》。你被提名了……沉默。
Just will.
Thanks for being our guest today.
Thanks for having me.
No, but you got nominated for...
You got nominated for Lala and what you won.
You got nominated for the favorite.
And you got nominated for...
Silence.
《鸟人》？是《鸟人》吗？是的。哦，是的，是的，是的，是的。你不得不和加利凡纳基斯一起工作。哦，天哪，我知道。真是个他妈的……噩梦。
The Birdman?
Is it the Birdman?
Yes.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you had to work with Galvanakis.
Oh, God, I know.
What a fucking...
What a nightmare.
演艺圈里有比扎克·加利凡纳基斯更没才华的人吗？你知道，从你的嘴唇到上帝的耳朵。我知道。我同意。我不能更同意了。他太，太甜了。无论如何，是的，不，他确实是。
Is there a less talented guy in showbiz
than Zach Alphanakis.
You know, from your lips to God's ears.
I know.
I agree.
I couldn't agree more.
He was so, so sweet.
Anyway, yeah, no, he really is.
你今晚要为我们做什么，你在看《黄金单身汉》吗？不。什么是《黄金单身汉》？我喜欢那个答案。我喜欢那个答案。什么是《黄金单身汉》？这是一个单身汉，但一个年纪大一点的家伙。
What are you going to do for us tonight,
and are you watching Golden Bachelor?
No.
What's Golden Bachelor?
I love that answer.
What is Golden Bachelor?
It's a Bachelor, but an older guy.
你不应该知道它是什么，艾玛·斯通。这就是为什么你是你。因为你不知道。我只是在这里。骨折，生病。不看《黄金单身汉》。好吧，现在我要去查一下并看它。肖恩经历了一个阶段。
You should never know what it is, Emma Stone.
This is why you are you.
Because you don't know.
I'm just out here.
Breaking Bones, getting sick.
Not watching Golden Bachelor.
Well, now I'm going to look it up and watch it.
Sean went for a phase.
艾玛·斯通，你永远不该知道那是什么。这就是你之所以是你的原因。因为你不知道。我只是在外面。断骨头，生病。不看《黄金单身汉》。好吧，现在我要去查一下并看看它。肖恩经历过一个阶段。
For a phase of his breaking bones, right?
Yep.
Early 20s, Chicago.
Hey, hey.
Oh, God.
Hey.
Emma, cool it, all right?
Okay, okay.
为了她骨折的阶段，对吧？是的。20岁出头，芝加哥。嘿，嘿。天哪。嘿。艾玛，冷静点，好吗？好的，好的。
Sorry, sorry about that.
Sorry.
Emma Stone.
We're going to let you go.
We're going to let you heal.
We're going to let you get better.
We're going to make you feel better.
I'm going to send some soup over.
抱歉，抱歉。抱歉。艾玛·斯通。我们要让你走了。我们要让你好好养伤。我们要让你好起来。我们要让你感觉好点。我会让人送些汤过去。
You don't need to send anything.
All right, good.
It'll be.
Okay, great.
I just saved myself a call to my assistant.
Thank you guys for having me.
I'm sorry I was such a, you know.
You're the best.
你不需要送任何东西。好吧，很好。那会。好的，太棒了。我刚省下了一个给我助理打电话的麻烦。谢谢你们邀请我。很抱歉我刚才那么，你知道的。你们是最棒的。
You're like incredibly fast hour.
Huge, huge, huge fan.
Huge fan.
You're the best.
Very, very sweet.
You're a, literally, you're a mega talent.
Yeah, mega.
Yeah.
你真是令人难以置信的快节奏一小时。超级、超级、超级粉丝。超级粉丝。你是最棒的。非常、非常贴心。你简直，你简直是个超级天才。是的，超级。是的。
True.
That's, you guys.
Emma.
Emma Stone.
Thank you guys so much.
Thanks for having me.
All the best.
真的。真的。那是，你们。艾玛。艾玛·斯通。非常感谢你们。谢谢你们邀请我。祝一切顺利。
Hey, Emma, one thing, I want you to remember one thing.
Yeah.
And I hope you've lived by this credo.
You can always say this to any guy.
If you want to be my lover, first you got to get with my friends.
Will?
If you want to be my lover.
That was truly beautiful.
嘿，艾玛，有一件事，我希望你记住一件事。是的。我希望你一直遵循这个信条。你可以随时对任何男人说这句话。如果你想成为我的爱人，你首先得和我的朋友们搞好关系。威尔？如果你想成为我的爱人。那真是太美了。
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I will take that with me.
Okay, got it.
You're welcome.
You not knowing that that was the spice girl's lyric is one of the more painful things.
Well, imagine what I think.
谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。我会记住这句话的。好的，明白了。不客气。你不知道那是辣妹合唱团的歌词，这是最令人痛苦的事情之一。好吧，想象一下我的想法。
thought, because I didn't know it was a lyric, I just thought he was just saying that stupid
crazy sentence.
No.
Like what?
I was trying to connect with her.
Did you just call the spice girl's stupid and crazy for the lyrics?
Or not a lyric.
If it was just a goodbye sentence for a podcast interview.
我想，因为我不知道那是歌词，我只是以为他是在说那句愚蠢疯狂的句子。不。像什么？我当时正试图和她套近乎。你刚才是不是说辣妹合唱团的歌词愚蠢又疯狂？或者不是歌词。如果那只是播客采访的告别语。
And this is where I log off.
What about when James Cameron, when James Cameron won the Academy Award for Best Director
of Titanic, I had not seen the movie.
But when he walks up on stage, he says, I'm king of the world.
Did you say you've never seen Titanic?
At the time I had not seen it
When I saw him go up on stage and say, I'm king of the world
I thought, oh no, what did he just say?
这就是我下线的时候了。那詹姆斯·卡梅隆呢，当詹姆斯·卡梅隆凭借《泰坦尼克号》获得奥斯卡最佳导演奖时，我还没看过这部电影。但当他走上舞台时，他说，我是世界之王。你是说你从来没看过《泰坦尼克号》？当时我确实没看过。当我看到他走上舞台说我是世界之王时，我想，哦不，他刚才说了什么？
I've never seen it, I know.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I know.
You got a lot of homework to do.
Jason's listening to wannabe by the Spadice Girls.
Will you're watching Titanic and Sean, just get Ricky, you know.
Fix your cat.
我从来没看过，我知道。是的。天哪。我知道。你有很多功课要做。杰森在听辣妹合唱团的《Wannabe》。威尔你在看《泰坦尼克号》，肖恩，去搞定瑞奇，你知道的。修理你的猫。
Get him a little bit.
Fix your cat.
Emma, thank you for being here.
Thank you.
Bye, honey.
Feel better.
Thank you.
Bye.
给他弄点。修理你的猫。艾玛，谢谢你来到这里。谢谢。再见，亲爱的。多保重。谢谢。再见。
Bye, bye, bye.
Good night.
Sean, you were right.
Great guest.
She did it while she was sick.
So nice for her dog.
Sick.
Sick as a dog.
再见，再见，再见。晚安。肖恩，你是对的。很棒的嘉宾。她是在生病的时候完成的。对她的狗真好。生病。病得像条狗一样。
This is worth, you know, when we do these late night records,
it's, you know, the stakes are high.
That it'd be a good guest and you nailed it there.
By the way, for the record, it was a 4 p.m. record.
So when you say late night, for most people,
they have a different.
Okay.
But the other thing is, I will say this.
这很值得，你知道，当我们进行这些深夜录制时，你知道，赌注很高。要成为一个好的嘉宾，你做得很好。顺便说一句，记录一下，这是下午4点的录制。所以当你说是深夜时，对大多数人来说，他们有不同的看法。好吧。但另一件事是，我会说这个。
And this is a compliment to you, J.B.
Not even a fucking, I'm not, there's no punchline.
She has a great work ethic.
Like a lot of people I know who started,
young in who were young in as actor as director whatever she has that same thing and you have
that same thing uh which is she's sick but blah blah i in all the years i've done stuff with you i've
never known you to call in sick not fucking once yeah oh there was uh plenty of times when i'd clear
my day when it was three three a m and i was uh still having fun yeah back sorry except for the one
这是对你的赞美，J.B.。甚至不是一个该死的，我不是，没有笑话。她有很棒的职业道德。就像我认识的许多年轻时就开始做演员或导演的人一样，她有同样的东西，你也有同样的东西，那就是她生病了，但等等，在我和你一起工作的这些年里，我从来没听说过你请病假，一次都没有。是的，哦，有很多次我清空了我的日程，当时是凌晨三点，我还在玩得很开心，是的，抱歉，除了那一次。
except for when you blew your cola out when we were doing that fight scene on the rest of
development.
You did.
You fought too hard.
You broke my colon.
I know, that's true.
But anyway, she does have that great thing.
She's always just, God, she's so good.
除了你在《发展受阻》拍摄打斗戏时弄伤了结肠。你确实弄伤了。你打得太用力了。你弄断了我的结肠。我知道，那是真的。但无论如何，她确实有那种很棒的特质。她总是，天哪，她太棒了。
You always, when you start listening off the stuff that she does and they're all so different,
you're like, yeah, yeah, I missed on her.
When an actor has never sucked, that's something.
She's in that category.
She's in that never sucked.
It's, I always say John Goodman, number one.
He's the first guy I always think of when I think never has never sucked.
And she's in that category.
当你开始列举她所做的事情，而且它们都如此不同时，你总是会想，是的，是的，我错过了她。当一个演员从来没有演砸过，那很不简单。她属于那一类。她属于那种从来没演砸过的人。我总是说约翰·古德曼，第一名。当我想到从来没演砸过的人时，他是我第一个想到的人。而她也属于那一类。
There are few people who,
fall into that category.
And she's one of them.
Yeah, she's incredible.
I didn't get to ask her about,
I want to talk more about La Land about how it shot.
Get ready well.
Next time.
很少有人属于那一类。她是其中之一。是的，她太不可思议了。我没来得及问她关于，我想多谈谈《爱乐之城》的拍摄方式。准备好。下次吧。
Next time, next time.
Honestly, nobody better.
There it comes.
Who's got it?
Yeah, well, I love Birdman, too, you know.
Oh, you know what I also like?
Do you ever see, bye, bye, birdie?
I couldn't even do it.
下次，下次。老实说，没人比她更好。它来了。谁有？是的，好吧，我也喜欢《鸟人》，你知道。哦，你知道我还喜欢什么吗？你看过《再见小鸟》吗？我甚至做不到。
I couldn't even, I'm Chris, you're going to do that.
You're fired.
Sean.
Bye, bye, bye, birdie.
Wait, what, bye, wait a second.
You can't just start saying.
It's just, it's too.
You're too tight.
我甚至不能，我是克里斯，你要那样做。你被解雇了。肖恩。再见，再见，再见，小鸟。等等，什么，再见，等一下。你不能就这样开始说。这太。你太紧张了。
See, it's too late.
It's too late to even come up with a buy.
Well, I was going to say this.
I love that she got her name from the baby Spice
because she's such a fan of the Spice.
Spice, girl.
That's good.
That'll do.
看，太晚了。连说再见都太晚了。好吧，我本来想说这个。我喜欢她从辣妹那里得到名字，因为她是辣妹的超级粉丝。辣妹。那很好。那样就行了。
Bye, everybody.
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico.
Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smart. Less.
再见，大家。Smartless是由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarf 100%有机且手工制作的。Smart。Less。